I am the master of my fate
I am the captain of my soul I am living
the dream
[Music]
and I want you to live the dream because
I'm not living the dream because I'm
special I'm living the dream because I
was obedient to the call of the dream so
often we spend our lives wishing and
hoping and hoping and wishing and
Desiring things this is what I know for
sure you don't get what you wish for you
don't even get what you hope for you get
what you believe so what is it you
believe and know to be God's dream for
you so I'd live in the dream I'm living
in the space of the dream and dreams
good dreams good
the dream is greater than anything that
I could have imagined I am responsible
for the choices that I make in my life I
am responsible
I am responsible so obviously I grew up
and was better able to articulate what
those words really mean and I discovered
in physics class the third law of motion
in physics says for every action it's
called Newton's Law
and it says for every action
there is an equal and opposite reaction
so what does that mean that means
everything that you are putting out into
the world every action bam there is an
equal and opposite reaction it means no
matter what you do the energy of what
you do what you say and most important
the energy of who you are is going out
into the world into your home into your
relationships and that energy is always
coming back to you you are responsible
for the energy that you are pulling out
into the world because that very energy
bam is coming right back to you every
single time whether you believe it or
not because it is law it is law it is
law that what you put out into the world
is coming back you have an intention for
the thing
and that the intention is going to
determine the outcome in this
Twitter tweet
meme mean
world that we've created for our
children the least we can do
is consider what we've done
and think about the young people the
future and individually collectively do
the best we can
to try and turn this thing around I
blame no one I look in the mirror on the
other side of it what an opportunity we
have because tomorrow's the first day of
the rest of our lives
everybody wants to fulfill
the highest truest expression of
yourself as a human being
that's what you're looking for
the highest truest expression of
yourself as a human being and because I
understand that I understand that if
you're working in a bakery
and that's where you want to be and that
may be the that may be what you've
always wanted to do is to bake pies for
people or bake cakes for people or to
offer your gift then then that's that's
for you and there's no difference
between you and me except that's how
that's your platform that's your show
every day so my understanding of that
has allowed me to you know everyone to
reach everyone and and there's no way
that you wouldn't because that's that's
what I truly feel so I was torn between
what the world was saying to me and what
I felt to be the truth for myself it
felt like an unnatural act for me
reporting
although I knew that a lot of people it
was glamorous and
I started to just inside myself think
what what do I really want to do what I
really want to do and I will say this
knowing what you don't want to do is the
best possible place to be if you don't
know what to do because knowing what you
don't want to do leads you to figure out
what is it you you really do want to do
overcoming failure or even life in
general for this whole process is an
inner journey and I'll explain what I
mean by that one of our biggest
challenges with failures is that we
start worrying about others approval and
validation that we're worried about
breaking the moment because of what
people would say we're worried about
taking a risk because we don't know how
someone's going to react he said what's
the most difficult thing you've ever
overcome in life
through my head ran sports injuries ran
health challenges ran emotional
challenges you know all these different
thoughts ran through my head and the
answer came to me and I said to myself
it's not even something I've overcome
but I felt it was the right thing to
share
I said that one of the most important
things or one of the most difficult
things that any of us can overcome and I
haven't overcome it is living for the
perception of others that's actually one
of the most difficult things we can
overcome when we forego the voice of our
ego and tune into the voice of our
intuition right our voice of our ego
says what will people say the voice of
our ego says is what if you don't make
it the voice of our ego says this part
will be safer this path is better
trodden on
and the voice of my intuition is saying
but you don't love that you love this
this is your heart's calling this is
what's going to make you happy every day
this if you can make this work
it will be phenomenal and that's why I
always remind myself and I've been
saying this to myself for years when
I've done jobs I didn't like when I've
done jobs that were okay and I've done
jobs over here I always said to myself
I'd rather die trying to make a
difference and not succeed then don't
try at all because what's exciting is
the Journey of everyday growing and
becoming the person I think I need to be
to attract the goal that I want that's
more exciting to me than even reaching
that goal believing every day that it's
possible believing that it's possible
looking at the Limitless possibility and
working in that way therefore a lot of
the challenges we have are simply to
give us responsibility for the success
that we're about to take on
I hate Plan B and I tell you why because
we have so many doubters we have so many
of those people that say no and you
can't do it that's impossible that is
okay because we just turn off
as I said earlier and we listen and we
hear that no being a yes you can't do it
do it you can't do it and all of that so
that that is possible to do that amongst
all the negative people around you but
when you start doubting yourself
that's very dangerous
because now what you're basically saying
is is that if my plan doesn't work
I have a fallback plan I have a plan B
and that means that you start thinking
about Plan B and every thought that you
put into Plan B you're taking away now
that thought and that energy from plan A
and it's very important
to understand that we function better
if there is no safety net because Plan B
becomes a safety net it says that if I
fail
then I fall and I get picked up and I
have something else there that was that
will protect me and that's not good
because people perform better when
there's no safety net people perform
better in sports and everything else
if you don't have a plan B I'm telling
you I've never ever
had a plan B
I say I made a full commitment that I'm
gonna go and be a party building
Champion I made a full commitment that
I'm gonna be in America I made a full
commitment that I'm going to get into
Show Business and I'm going to be a
leading man no matter what it takes I
will do the work I would do the work
over and over and over
until I get it said to me it is very
dangerous to have a plan B because
you're cutting yourself off from the
chance of really succeeding and the
reason one of the main reasons why
people want to have a plan p is because
they are worried about failing
what is if I fail then I don't have
anything else
well let me tell you something don't be
afraid of failing because there's
nothing wrong with failing you have to
fail in order to climb that ladder
there's no one that doesn't fail